I'm Bob Schiller.
Uh,
I have the pleasure of introducing
this a [inaudible] lecture. Uh,
Lawrence Lawrence Summers.
I wanted to say first that the [inaudible]
lecture series was founded by an
anonymous donor in honor
of Arthur [inaudible],
who was professor of
economics here at Yale. Uh,
who later became a chairman of the Council
of Economic Advisers who founded with
William Brainerd,
the Brooking's papers on economic activity
and was widely admired both here at
Yale and,
uh,
around the world as an
economist that has a,
had a lot of impact on policy,
uh, economist with a purpose.
Uh,
so it's altogether fitting that we have
Lawrence Summers here as our OE can
lecture for this year.
Uh, very summers. Um,
he'd go through his career briefly.
He started out at age 16
at MIT as a physics major.
Um, fortunately for us, he switched
into economics, uh, at an very,
as soon as a teenager.
Uh,
he got his PhD at Harvard. He, uh,
got tenure at Harvard at one of
the, he's one of the earliest, uh,
an aid at age 28. Um, in 1993,
he won the John Bates Clark Medal for
the best economist under the age of 40.
Uh, he joined the staff of the
Council of economic advisors.
He was under secretary of Treasury,
uh, for international affairs.
He was chief economist at the World Bank.
He was the US Secretary of Treasury.
Uh,
he was president of Harvard University.
and now he is a university professor at
Harvard and also a director at de Shaw.
His research, uh, has been truly stunning.
I say I've always been a huge admirer
of it and it covers many fields,
public finance, labor, macro
economics and finance in particular.
Uh,
I thought I would just conclude my
introduction with a couple of famous Larry
Summers quotes. Uh, this, these quotes
are advice to graduate students,
but they might as well be
advice to any researcher. Uh,
there he is quoted as saying,
uh,
you might as well work on big problems
because it takes just as much time to
write a paper on a little
problem as on a big problem.
Uh, and, uh, another bit
of advice to students,
um,
do your research on the economy,
not on the economic.
And so I think that that's
a bit of wise advice,
but I think that, uh, that, uh,
to me that says something about
the essence of his research style,
uh,
he's been extremely potent in his work
on very important results that kind of
shape our view of the world.
Uh, and I think that, uh,
it's this research style that is part
of the reason why he's been tapped for
such important physicians. So, uh,
I'm pleased to introduce Larry Summers.
[inaudible]
thank you Bob very much for that,
uh,
overly generous introduction.
Uh,
at least one thing he
said wasn't quite right.
It may or may not have been.
Economics is good luck
when I left physics,
but it was surely the good luck of
the physics profession when I left.
Uh,
physics.
Yes.
Just a minute.
I've got an elaborate
program of microphones they
wished me to turn on here.
How's that?
No, I just turned that one off.
Okay, good. Everybody happy?
Um,
I appreciated your generosity
in reflecting on the different,
uh,
sectors in which I'd had a chance
to work when I first moved from,
uh, the university to, uh, Washington.
People ask me,
well,
what's different about being a senior
treasury official from being a professor
at Harvard?
And I realized the answer,
that one was easy.
As a professor at Harvard,
the single worst thing you could do was
to sign your name to something you had
not written yourself. On the other
hand, in the Treasury Department,
it was a mark of effectiveness to
do so as frequently as possible.
And then I got back to Harvard and had
the honor of serving as its president.
And people ask me what was different
about the university from Washington.
And in those first months I gave an
answer that in retrospect seems slightly
breathtaking in its naive tay.
I said,
Washington is so political.
There's so much opposition.
University, it's very different from
that. We're all on the same side.
It is a real honor to be here at Yale
and it is a particular honor to deliver
the Arthur oaken lectures.
I am told that I first met art Okin when
I was one week old as he and my father
were close friends during the time when
they were assistant professors at a Yale
together.
And in fact,
I grew up until a certain age calling
him uncle art and I don't have many vivid
memories,
but I have a quite vivid memory and
I was able to go back and a place,
the year it was 1969 and art
delivered a set of lectures,
probably a set of lectures like this one,
um, at the University of Pennsylvania.
And he stayed at our house and he stayed
up telling my parents a whole set of
stories about life as
an economist, uh, with,
uh, Lyndon Johnson, some of the
stories are a little too Raunchy, uh,
to, uh, repeat, uh, ray here.
But it was the first inkling I had that
this academic research stuff like my
parents did really could
have a very direct and real,
uh, impact on the policy
arena. I remember,
especially somehow,
I don't know what determines what makes
an impression on you when you're 15,
but a 14.
But my father telling me the
story of how there was a,
and I have no idea where
this story is actually true,
but the story he told was that there
was a publication that the Department of
Commerce published called BCD,
which stood for business cycle digest,
which compiled all the facts about the
business cycle and whether the economy
was up or whether the economy was down,
but that because of all this stuff
that economists had figured out,
uh,
like art,
we now had these practical policies that
we could use so that when there was a
recession,
we'd stopped the recession from happening.
And when there was an excessive boom,
we'd smooth off the boom.
And so we didn't necessarily have to
have business cycles anymore. And so,
but we liked calling the publication BCD.
So art had had the clever idea
of renaming the publication,
the business conditions digest to
celebrate the success of a Keynesian
economics. Time went on. And the first,
um,
great success if there ever were any
great successes of my career as a graduate
student came when, uh,
Art Okin and George Perry,
um, invited, uh, Kim Clark.
And I to give what was the first
significant paper that I had written as a
graduate student on labor market
dynamics and unemployment at,
uh, the Brooking's papers
on economic activity, uh,
conference. And it was the, uh,
thrill of our young lives.
And it was also a vastly,
vastly better paper in the form in which,
uh, it was, uh, published, uh,
than it was in the form in which
it was originally written. Uh,
thanks to, uh, art.
And I have a final memory that pertains,
uh,
to art that also says something
about art. I remember, uh,
sometime in the early 1980s,
uh,
sitting at the lunch table
in the MIT faculty club,
and in a way that some of you who
know me won't find surprising,
I was a declaiming on various subjects
with a certain lack of reticence that
perhaps, uh, was not commensurate
with my lack of knowledge.
And I asserted some proposition.
And Paul Samuelson turned
to me and he said, Larry,
I just wrote a eulogy for Art
Oakland who died recently.
And I said that in all the years
that I had known art. Okay.
Art Okin had never said a stupid thing.
Well,
Larry,
now I won't be able to say that about you.
And one of the things that it gives me
particular pleasure in along with Greg
Mankiw taking over the editorship of,
uh,
the Brooking's papers on economic activity
from bill Brainard and George Perry,
who have done such a stellar
job for the last 25 years,
is the knowledge that it was a project,
uh,
that had been initiated by art.
It was a project that had been initiated
by art out of a conviction that I have
tried to live by in my career.
And that I hope in some
small way to illustrate, uh,
with my remarks, uh, here, uh,
today that serious economic thinking can
one understand the world much better.
That with the aid of the metaphors and
the models and the measurements to come
from serious economic,
uh,
thinking one can direct economic policies
in better and in more sensible ways.
And as a consequence,
the lives of very large numbers of people,
none of,
most of whom will never hear of
economics and certainly will not study.
It's details will in some way the
improved by having a higher incomes,
by facing less risk,
by being more secure as they go through,
uh,
their livelihoods.
And it's in that spirit that I want
to reflect today on some aspects of
macroeconomic thinking and experience
and then some aspects of financial
thinking and experience and how
they bear on financial crisis.
And then tomorrow on the particular
financial crisis that we faced right now,
what has been done,
what may happen,
what should be done and what can be done
over the longer term to make the return
of such a crisis, more
important, more, uh, less, uh,
less likely.
Art was preoccupied through most of his
career with the central macro economic
issue of assuring stable growth and
to use language that's perhaps a more
congenial to older than younger ears,
avoiding underemployment
and output, uh, gaps.
It's revealing that the journal he founded
was called the Brooking's papers on
economic activity suggesting a concern
with the cyclical performance of the
economy.
He surely as much as anyone would have
subscribed to Jim Tobin's famous dictum
that it takes a heap of
Harberger triangles to fill
an Okin in gap or that the
macro economic issues of recession
and depression are terribly,
terribly important relative
to the Microeconomic, uh,
efficiencies that are a preoccupation
of a very large number of economists.
This idea,
this first idea that oak
and gaps exist and are large
and very important relative to micro
economic inefficiencies is one that is
increasingly unfashionable,
uh,
today discussing them within the
context of what has been called.
Although I suppose it can't
be called that anymore.
The new classical macroeconomics
is almost impossible.
There's no role for any kind of gap.
It's much like discussing epicycles,
uh,
with a modern astronomer.
But even within the Keynesian tradition,
the excepted versions of the Keynesian
model greatly circumscribe the scope for
what was arts major concern
under employment and,
uh,
the output gap.
Because if one thinks about the uh,
centerpiece of,
uh,
the supply side of any
macro economic model, um,
almost any macroeconomic model post,
uh,
1980 in some form or other,
it has the implication that,
uh,
the change in inflation is in some
way dependent on the output gap.
Perhaps it's the change in inflation,
perhaps even more problematically. Uh,
it's the unexpected
component of inflation.
Perhaps the causation runs the other way
and the output gap is related to that
is caused by the change in
inflation or is caused by the,
uh, level of unexpected, uh, inflation.
Any equation,
any theory of output that has that
property has a simple consequence if you
aggregate it over a long period of time,
namely that if you look at the difference
between inflation at the end of the
period and inflation at the beginning
of the period or equivalently,
if you look at the average
level of unexpected inflation,
which has to be zero,
it will relate to the size
of, uh, the output gap.
And therefore if one thinks of a
steady state as being a state in which
unexpected inflation averages zero or a
state in which the accelerate the change
in inflation average is zero.
You know what the output gap has,
uh,
got to be,
it has got to average zero.
This doesn't mean there's
no role for cyclical policy,
but it has the very strong
implication that what you gain,
um,
in the booms you lose in the recessions,
that if you have deeper recessions,
you will be able to have larger booms.
That if you have larger booms,
you will be able to have a show.
You will be,
you will be forced to
have a deeper recessions.
And in a sense,
if one accepts this idea,
the subject of cyclical fluctuations
in macroeconomics becomes an order of
magnitude less important than it was.
If one maintains some older idea in which
it's possible to have output gaps that
are not offset by a subsequent,
uh,
gains in output.
To be sure and much has
been made of the point.
At a certain moments,
there may be some impact on nonlinear
of nonlinearity in the relationship
between the gap and the change in
inflation or unexpected inflation.
If this relationship is a nonlinear,
then it's possible that
by running smoother,
a smoother economy, one can run
a somewhat higher pressure, uh,
economy.
But in a world where economy attritions
struggle to estimate any kind of a
Phillips curve, the idea that one
can measure with any precision,
a nonlinearity of this kind is
at the very least problematic.
And so ironically,
the Keynesian model as it came,
uh,
to evolve the Keynesian model that and
the Keynesian discussion that had as its
centerpiece,
the Phillips curve in some form,
in almost all of the forms in
which the Phillips Curve, uh, came,
was quite skeptical of the role of
macroeconomic policy in effecting average
levels of output through time.
Very little room for art Ocwens dedication
to closing output gaps or maintaining
a higher pressure economy as a way of
spurring economic growth or as a way of
promoting a more equal, uh, income, uh,
distribution
arts lab.
The last decade of arts professional
work was directed at a questions that in
one way or another, uh, relate, uh,
to, uh, these equations.
His final book was entitled,
uh,
prices and quantities and his dominant
professional preoccupation was,
uh,
in his last years with how the rate of
inflation could be brought down with a
minimum level of the output gap with,
as he would have put it,
a minimum sacrifice,
a ratio.
It's not hard to understand why these
questions relating to inflation and
output.
We're preoccupations of Arts juring his,
uh,
professional, uh, lifetime.
It's interesting to think
about a US business cycle,
uh,
history when people like me gave
talks about the economic outlook to a
nonacademic audiences.
A 15 or 20 years ago,
it was a considered a
cleverness to observe that
American economic expansions do
not die of old age.
They are murdered by the Federal
Reserve with inflation control as a,
the motive.
And if one thought about,
thinks about a universe of,
uh,
experience,
the three Eisenhower
recessions that were formative,
um, for, uh, art, although, uh,
I believe the second of them
coincided with my birth. The, um,
1966,
1967 economic downturn more conspicuously
the major downturns in 74 75 in the
wake of the oil supply
shock. And in 1980, 1982,
the Volcker disinflation these were
most of the experience we had with the
business cycle.
In a substantial swath
of economic history.
The economy expanded
in one way or another.
Inflation got out of control,
people got nervous about inflation.
The Fed hit the bar,
the Fed, uh, hit the brakes.
Interest rates spike,
the yield curve inverted the economy,
uh, slowed to be sure there
were great controversies,
uh, about, uh, how,
what exactly the mechanism was.
What was the role of credit rationing
in the housing sector versus higher
interest rates? To what extent did
the transmission mechanism take place,
uh, through, uh, Tobin's Q,
but if one asked what was
the cause of downturns?
The cause was monetary.
The accounts of business cycle historians,
uh,
who tracked events,
um,
were couched in those terms.
The enormously influential
monetary history of the
United States emphasized the
role of monetary contractions
and of Federal Reserve,
uh,
Federal Reserve policies.
The academic issues of the day,
which focused quite critically on
the questions of price. Rigidity,
therefore led to a natural focus as
the canonical experiment of suppose you
reduce em the money stock,
what happens to the level of output in
the short run and why does that happen?
And so the prevailing view about business
cycles was that they were determined
by monetary policy.
And what led to contractionary monetary
policy was either a mistake by the Fed
or a necessary action,
um,
by the Fed as inflation, uh, accelerated.
But it is interesting to contemplate that
if one looks before or after what one
might think of as,
uh,
the Okin period and tries to give a
simple account of what was behind the
business cycles, uh, that, uh, took place.
One offers a rather different,
uh,
kind of,
story 1907 is linked to a financial panic.
It couldn't have been caused by the
feds since the Fed. Uh, it didn't exist.
It didn't exist yet.
In 1929.
The actions of the Federal Reserve in
1928 or 1929 may or may not have been a
crucial causative factor,
but there's a reason they talk about
the stock market crash as a prelude,
uh, to, uh, the depression. Uh,
the dominant influences
were indogenous too,
or the workings of the financial system.
And if one thinks about the three most
recent instances of cyclical fluctuation
in, uh, the, uh, United in
the United in the United States,
um,
the 1990 1992 case can be debated.
There was an oil shock. There had been
some tightening of monetary policy,
but I think most observers would assign
a dominant influence to the problems in
the financial system associated with the
SNLs and the overextension of banks in
a real estate lending.
There's no question that almost any close
watcher if asked to say what was the
2001 recession about,
they would say bursting of
the technology bursting of,
uh,
the technology bubble.
And I'll have more to say about,
uh,
the 2008, um, uh,
recession a little later and,
uh,
tomorrow including some speculations on
the probability that there is one. Um,
but no one would say of the current
fluctuation that it reflected the Federal
Reserve's excessive or necessary effort
to curb inflation in product a price
markets rather,
they would attribute it in one way or
another to something indogenous to uh,
the financial system.
The debates would turn on whether it was
best thought of in terms of a housing
price bubble,
whether it was best thought of as a
matter having to do with the extension,
excessive extension of a sub,
uh,
pro of a subprime credit,
whether it was,
uh,
a reflection of a generalized
excessive complacency, uh,
in credit markets that led to the
extension of financial institutions.
All of those questions could,
uh,
be debated but no serious dispute about,
the proposition that he
came out of the workings of,
uh,
the financial system.
And so with this history before us in
thinking about macro economic policy and
in thinking about cyclical fluctuations,
it seems to me appropriate that we
at least consider redirecting some
macroeconomic attention from traditional
preoccupations with the price setting
process,
the Phillips curve and disinflation
to more traditional Keynesian,
uh,
preoccupations with the workings
of the financial system,
uh, with, uh,
animal spirits with a,
if you like,
shocks to the I s curve that come out
of the workings of the financial system.
It,
this view I would suggest is certainly
confirmed by less detailed reflection on
international experience.
If one thinks about the two most dramatic
OEC macro economic events of the last
20 years, they are almost certain oes,
excuse me, presidents, the Deo, uh,
permanent OACD, uh, member
events. So I exclude,
uh, the drama of which, uh, you are a, uh,
you are so central. Um,
uh, yeah, me too. Uh,
so Centra,
so central a part,
they were almost certainly the Japanese,
uh,
financial crisis followed by depression
in the 1990s and the dramatic declines
in output associated with the failure
of the banking system to the point where
it needed to be nationalized
in the Nordic countries in, uh,
the early 1990s.
Indeed,
it is interesting to note
that in recent years,
uh,
financial crises have a,
become a pervasive one
always remembers the, uh,
comments one makes about
economic fluctuations that
prove to be pressured and
forgets the ones that prove
to have been completely wrong.
And I am no exception.
Uh,
so I will recall that I was fond of
observing in 2005 and 2006 that if one
looked at the last, uh, 20 years,
there had been six, uh, six or seven,
six major, uh, financial crises,
the 1987 stock market crash,
the 1990 savings and loan,
uh, real estate crash,
the 1995, uh, Mexican, uh,
crash. Some would argue that
if this is a u s list, um,
that Mexico doesn't belong,
one could have that argument.
The 1997 Asian financial crisis,
the,
uh, events associated
with Ltcm and Russia that,
uh, President Clinton and
Secretary Ruben at the time, uh,
labeled the most serious financial
crisis since the Second World War,
since the Second World War and the 2001,
um, financial crisis associated with, uh,
the bursting of the tech bubble
problems in the high yield sector,
um, of where the subsequent, uh,
problems in capital markets, uh,
exemplified by what happened,
uh, at, uh, [inaudible].
It is interesting to ask the question
whether there is some relation between all
of these events because what
I've suggested so far is
that if one distinguishes
the last generation from the preceding
a generation in the proceeding
generation,
financial crises were relatively rare.
Business cycles were caused by
the Federal Reserve eliminating,
uh,
Federal Reserve's concern about
inflation for the last generation.
Um, business cycles have
been associated with, uh,
financial,
uh,
crisis and the Federal Reserve has not
caused downturns through its concern with
inflation. How were
these events, uh, linked?
I'm not entirely, uh, sure. Uh,
sitting in the Brooking's papers
meetings for all these years,
I've learned how bill
Nordhaus is hard to satisfy a,
sometimes people have t statistics of
three and bill pronounces them to be quote
unquote Darwinian,
um,
and reflecting the data
mining of the author.
And on other occasions they
have only a few observations,
in which case they're deemed to have
committed one observation, a econometrics.
I'm going to commit about
four observation, uh,
econometrics and offer the hypothesis
that the right way to understand,
uh,
this pattern is that we achieved that,
arts generation.
And then Paul Volcker achieved
a hugely important thing.
They achieved a measure of credibility
and commitment to non-inflationary
monetary policies that enabled inflation
expectations to be kept in check.
And that just as success in
curing infectious disease
leads there to be far more
cancer than there was before infectious
disease was brought in check.
So to the achievement
of disinflation leads,
uh, to an economy, uh,
in which expansions are
enabled to continue until
they lead to the complacency
in confidence associated, uh, with, uh,
financial, uh, crisis. Perhaps, uh,
we will have 6% inflation two years
from now and the Fed will cause a risk.
Fed will find it necessary to engineer
a recession in this theory will fall
completely by the wayside.
Perhaps there is an alternative,
more compelling, uh, explanation, uh,
for this pattern.
But for now I would have dues,
uh,
the hypothesis that the
increased incidents of
financial crisis and the closer
relationship between financial crisis
and economic downturns is a byproduct of
our success in achieving low and credible,
uh,
inflation and the associated great,
uh, moderation whether or not,
um, we can, um,
except that idea as to why a financial
crisis seems to have been the cause of
previous recessions where
it was not previously.
The empirical observation,
uh,
stands that financial crises are frequent
and that not infrequently when there
is a financial crisis,
it leads to some
significant disruption in,
uh, real, uh, economic activity.
It follows that the causes
of a financial crisis,
the policy response to a financial crisis
need to occupy a larger part of our
consideration of macroeconomics. Then, uh,
they have, uh, uh, then, uh, they have,
uh,
traditionally I should
suggest also that this is,
this conclusion is reinforced by
the observation that whereas disinflation
recession lends itself very much to
the unfortunate conservation argument
I presented at the beginning,
uh, that suggested that, uh,
you couldn't really alter the output
gap over long periods of time if you did
not want to accept changes in inflation.
It is easy to understand financial
crisis and the associated downturns and
output as a reduction in aggregate
supply and therefore highly plausible to
believe that the better management of
financial crisis or the prevention of
financial crisis will lead not
just to a smoother path of output,
but a path that by avoiding downturns
has a higher average over long periods of
time and therefore is more successful
in achieving the goal that aren't
[inaudible] and Jim
Tobin and Yale for many,
many years set a four
macro economic policy of,
uh, raising the average, uh,
level of, uh, output.
Now, discussions of a
financial crisis, um,
tend to have the character of a accident.
Uh,
investigations.
There are many different suspects,
great numbers of details.
Our mustard, uh, to tell, uh,
the, uh, story.
There are always particular
words associated with
particular financial crises.
One talks about portfolio insurance in
the context of the 1987 crash when talks
about a test to Bono's in
the context of, uh, the,
uh, Mexican experience.
One talks about bubbles,
psychology in the context of
the Nass of the Nasdaq, uh,
experience. One uses the
t one speaks about, uh,
the vicissitudes of the separation
between the originators and the owners of
mortgages. In talking about, uh,
the current subprime mortgage crisis,
it all brings to mind a Tolstoy's
observation that every happy family is the
same and every unhappy family
is a miserable I in its own way.
And it is all correct or
not all of it is correct.
But in each of, uh, the, uh,
crises,
there are important elements
of institutional detail of
particular practice that
explain how the story played out, uh, in,
uh, the way, uh, that it did.
But I want to suggest that there is some
common structure that lie behind the
various phenomena that are
associated with a financial crisis.
The understanding of which can
at least help us to think about,
uh, the mechanism of
crisis and perhaps, uh,
the appropriate, uh, policy, uh,
responses for thinking
about financial crises.
Uh,
economics has a classic metaphor that
captures a many elements of the problem.
It's a set of ideas that,
uh,
go back at least to Badgett in economic
history and are known to current
economic theorists as a diamond did Vig,
uh,
phenomena.
And the idea is simple,
powerful and uh,
incomplete.
Imagine a bank,
the bank takes deposits,
the deposits can be withdrawn
at any moment or at least
can be withdrawn at high
frequency.
It takes the deposits and it
lends the money for projects.
The projects have a higher rate of return,
then the deposits do.
But the projects take some significant
time to complete and there is no market
for a half finished project.
Think about that financial institution,
perhaps it also chooses to keep a
portion of its deposits on hand.
I in a cash,
a moment's reflection on,
uh,
that financial institution,
um,
will cause you to recognize that it
is subject to multiple equilibrium.
If everyone believes that
the bank will remain healthy,
the bank will in fact remain healthy.
Depositors all can be paid back.
The project will be completed.
The bank shareholders are better off.
The of the depositors are better off.
The entrepreneurs who have been lent
money for their projects are better off.
It is a nash equilibrium
and everyone is better off.
It is not.
However,
the only Nash equilibrium a
moment's thought will also
cause you to realize that
if everyone else is taking
their money out of the bank,
then you are well advised to take your
money out of the bank as soon as you can
because the bank is not going to be
able to pay off all of the claims on it.
And so a solvent bank is subject
to self fulfilling prophecy.
It can either remain solvent or it can uh,
fail depending upon the state,
not just of expectations but
in a manner much like canes,
beauty contest,
expectations of others expectations.
If I expect that you expect that tn
expects that the bank is going to fail and
that he is going to withdraw money,
then the safer thing for me
to do is to withdraw money.
If one wants a simple theory of why,
if you go to any American town and you
look for the most solidly built building
with the most impressive facade,
it will be a building that
was used as a bank. Um,
particularly if it was constructed
before the era of deposit insurance.
It is precisely this notion of multiple
equilibrium that explains why banks more
than other institutions are at such pains
to project credibility and to project
a permanence.
Notice that this metaphor is very powerful
and is very suggestive of a case for
activism because it suggests that there
are multiple possibilities to which the
free market will be subject.
It suggests that if
coordination can be achieved,
there are possibilities that are
unambiguously better for everyone and
possibilities that are worse for everyone
and it suggests a natural role for
government as a coordinator or as
a guarantor in favor of the better
equilibrium.
Now to be sure the more
rigorous and skeptical,
uh, among, uh,
among you will have noticed that I slipped
and important issue by in telling the
story,
I said quickly that there was no
market for unfinished projects.
It's hard to understand why if it's a
certainty that all unfinished projects are
going to succeed.
And it's a certainty that
when they do succeed,
the bank will have more money
and have enough money to pay off.
It's, uh, depositors.
Why there will not be some
profit maximizing actor
who is prepared to come in
and buy those unfinished,
uh,
projects and in the process
make the depositors hole.
And so in the language that is always
used in talking frequently used in,
uh, talking about, uh, financial, uh,
financial, uh, crisis,
it's hard to understand how you can have
a liquidity problem without at least
the possibility of a solvency problem.
And once you have the possibility
of a solvency problem,
it becomes less clear just how much
you're making everybody better off by
lending the money or by allowing the
projects to be partially completed.
Nonetheless,
this liquidity nonetheless,
this diamond did vague bank run metaphor
has been very powerful in influencing
financial policy in a wide range of,
uh,
situations.
It was this idea that
was the justification,
albeit without mentioning diamond
or did figs name that, uh,
Secretary Rubin and I used in explaining
to President Clinton why it was
important that we support Mexico in,
uh, 19, uh, nine in, uh,
1995 and in countless other efforts
of what their supporters call support
programs and their
opponents call bailouts in,
uh, financial history when, uh,
institutions or,
uh,
countries or individuals in Diskin
financial distress we're provided with
support.
The concept of it's a liquidity problem.
So by providing support we can coordinate
around the positive equilibrium was,
uh,
invoked.
So this idea of a bank run or a set of
bank runs and the provision of support
provides a powerful way of
thinking about a destructive gap,
increasing financial crisis.
And it certainly fits a
variety of situations. Uh,
the situation that Mexico faced in 19,
uh,
85,
perhaps the situation that a bear
Stearns faced several weeks ago,
certainly the situation that the Fed
was concerned about that has led it to
provide financial support in the form
of backstop facilities of many kinds to,
uh, many, uh, financial institutions.
But it does not really address or seem
in an obvious way to apply to many of the
financial crises that, uh, we observe.
Many of the financial
crises that we observe,
think of the 1987 crash or think about
events in the housing market or mortgage
market today involve freely traded assets.
They don't involve banks,
they don't seem to involve a bank runs.
What I'd like to suggest,
and I can only suggest
this in an imprecise way,
is that an important sense?
There is a broad class of behavior that
goes on in speculative markets that is
in its character, very similar to, uh,
the character of a bank run.
One way of thinking about,
uh,
that a bank run is to think about the
value that you associate with a deposit
claim on the bank in question.
There's this troubled, there's this
bank in normal times I have a $1
deposit.
The deposit is worth $1.
That's $1 deposit. It's
worth $1. That's easy.
Now imagine that the price of that
deposit falls because there comes to be a
question whether that bank is going to
succeed or whether that bank is going to
fail or for that matter that the price
of that claim falls because of doubts
about the solvency of uh,
the bank.
Do I as a depositor wished to put more
deposits into the bank because the price
has fallen?
We're do I wish to sell my
claim as rapidly as I can?
If you think about it for a minute,
the situations in which the value
of deposits are falling are the very
situations in which you are most
eager to sell those deposits.
Back to,
uh,
the bank to go back to,
economics is a standby.
The most basic idea that we teach
freshmen and egg that we teach freshmen in
economics is a,
the law of supply and demand,
the stabilizing nature of markets
markets as a negative feedback mechanism.
We tell the story in lots of
ways. There's a surplus. Uh,
there's a,
uh,
there's a surplus of apples
when there's a surplus of,
uh, when there's a, when
there's a surplus of, uh,
apples,
uh,
the price falls and then there is
demand increases and then there isn't a
surplus of apples anymore. There's a
shortage of apples. The price rises,
then there isn't a shortage,
then there isn't a
shortage of apples anymore.
And our basic image of the economic
system is as a self equilibrating a system
with a single equilibrium
that is determined by that
law of supply and demand.
If the demand curve
slopes in the wrong way,
if a falling price leads to less demand
or equivalent and the two more supply,
then none of our normal intuitions,
uh,
work price falls in response,
uh, to, uh,
excess demand and rises in response
to excess supply magnifying,
uh,
the excess.
If there's a single equilibrium,
it can be unstable.
If the demand curve has the more exotic
shape that goes with some people,
uh, responding to, uh, price,
uh,
over some range by reducing demand
and others responding by increasing,
uh, demand. Then there
are other possibilities.
I draw here a diagram
that's been produced, uh,
many times in many
different, uh, contexts. Uh,
where you engage in the intellectual
exercise of this is complicated.
This is wild.
This is really crazy.
Let's think of a reason why the
demand curve could have both slopes.
Let's suppose that sometimes it has the
normal slope and sometimes it has the
other than if it fits together in the
right way. There can be two equilibria.
One good and one bad.
And one could clearly
proliferate examples of uh,
this kind.
So if there is a mechanism present
more generally in financial markets,
that causes the price of,
uh,
the,
the demand for financial
assets to increase with a
price were to decrease with,
uh, supply, uh, or to, or to,
or causes,
um,
a demand to decrease as price falls.
Then one has the possibility
of instability that has
very much the character of
the bank run.
Is this a reasonable hypothesis,
uh, to, uh, main, uh,
to maintain, uh, this brings us,
and I will not dwell on this at any
length to a broad set of issues,
uh, associated, uh,
with a behavioral, uh, finance, uh,
like Bob Schiller.
I was very struck when I encountered the
assertion of Mike Jensen and others in
the late 1970s that the efficient market
hypothesis was the best established
fact in, uh, the social
sciences. By the way,
that didn't necessarily mean that
it was a well established a fact.
Um, but as Jensen, uh, used the term, uh,
that was its meaning.
And I,
I have to say that as I make that
remark about social sciences,
I'm reminded of,
um,
the observation somebody wants to offered
that if you have to call it science,
it isn't, um, cognitive science,
Christian science, political
science, social science,
social science.
And so I have ever since hearing that,
never used the term economic science,
uh,
to refer to, to refer to any, uh,
phenomenon.
These issues were crystallized,
uh, for, uh, for me,
I had followed a Bob's,
uh,
Bob's work on a excess volatility and
tried to contribute some of my own on the,
uh,
power of a statistical tests.
And I was struck by the bitterness
of the controversies that surrounded,
um,
uh,
Bob's working on excess volatility in
particular were so many in finance,
seems to regard a tax on the efficient
market hypothesis in rather than the way
they would regard attacks
on their spouses. Um, or,
uh, children that, uh,
called for not just a
rational rejoinder, but, uh,
some effort at the destruction of,
uh,
the assailant.
But I remember that my sense of the issue
and the merits where my sympathies had
always been,
uh,
with Bob crystallized in the summer
of 1987 and the summer of 1987,
there were a certain set of
facts that were very clear.
It was very clear in the summer of 1987
that if you divided stock prices by any
interesting denominator,
they were at an extraordinarily
high level earnings.
Give it in sales, GNP.
If you were at Yale,
the value of the kappa,
that you added the debt and you divided
by the value of the capital stock,
it didn't matter all denominators.
Uh,
stock prices were extraordinarily high.
And then the question was how
to interpret that observation.
And there were two
interpretations on offer.
One was the conventional interpretation
that would have seemed the only
plausible interpretation to
anyone who read the newspaper,
which was that stocks have been going
great and a lot of people wanted to buy
stock and therefore they all tried to
buy stock and there are only so was so
much stock and the price went up
and as a consequence
of the price going up,
it was probably true that the return going
forward was going to be lower than it
had been before the price went up.
That was one interpretation that seemed
the obvious and natural interpretation.
You alternative interpretation
was that for some reason,
people who used to demand 8%
expected returns to buy stocks,
we're now demand had somehow had decided
for some reason that they'd really be
justice,
that they'd really be,
they used to demand 8% to buy stocks
given the risk. But all of a sudden,
for whatever reason, and the reason
was never spelled out with any clarity,
they now we're happy to accept a 6% rate
of return and therefore all the future
dividends and all the future earnings
were discounted at a lower level.
So there was an a way,
a simple intuition for
deciding what you believed.
Did you believe that returns were low
because stock prices were high or did you
believe that stock prices were high
because people had decided they were
perfectly content with low returns?
Well,
it was an easy way to distinguish those
hypotheses. And Bob did it at the time,
which was to ask people what
returns they were expecting,
what returns they were settling for.
And the answer suggested that if anything,
they favored high returns rather than
they expected higher returns than they had
previously. Not Lower returns
than they had previously.
Why do I dwell on all of this?
Because it is a first example of what I
actually think are substantial variety
of mechanisms,
all of which can produce this kind of
positive feedback behavior in a financial
markets. The first and easiest
mechanism for understanding,
um, why, uh, there will be
positive feedback behavior or equivalently
a decline in demand is price falls
and an increase in price and demand
as price rises is the extrapolate of
expectations that come
from recent experiences.
One of the things I learned painfully
being involved with managing the dollar as
secretary of the Treasury was
there is absolutely no way,
no matter how powerful you are,
and no matter how clever you are,
that the dollar can be
lower without falling.
It cannot happen no matter how much you
want to have a falling dollar with low
dollar without a falling dog.
And in just the same way a rising stock
price leads to a higher stock price.
And therefore if people demand
more after increases in price,
they are demanding more as price rises.
That's one mechanism through which
there can be positive feedback is second
mechanism, which Bob has put
considerable emphasis on, uh,
in, uh, his, uh,
writing is a social contagion.
Uh,
it's, people persuade other people.
People look at other people basically.
Uh, the bubbles psychology, uh,
takes hold as a social dynamic,
uh,
not necessarily related,
to any rational assessment of
the future behavior of markets.
A third mechanism is a one that
can easily be given a rational,
uh, explanation. I am the risk manager.
John is a trader.
I don't actually know whether
John knows anything or not. Uh,
he says he does and,
but,
and he's got a complicated story and
I can't quite tell how much he knows.
He just lost a lot of money.
Should I have more confidence in John
or should I have less confidence in John
knowing that he lost a lot,
that he just lost?
Um, a, a lot of money?
Probably I should have less confidence,
uh,
in John and as an empirical,
proposition, his risk manager
will have less confidence,
uh, in, uh, John.
And so positions that do not succeed
have less capital associated with them.
Then positions that do succeed.
Again,
creating this kind of positive,
uh,
feedback.
A fourth mechanism that will create a,
this kind of, uh, positive, uh,
feedback,
uh,
derives from a leverage.
Anyone who buys on margin or any
financial institution that has a capital
requirement,
when
they lose money,
there is a margin call or a need,
uh, to uh, generate, uh,
capital which can lead
to the liquidation of,
uh,
the,
that can lead to the
liquidation of positions.
Again, falling price, more, uh, selling
a fifth example and a fifth source of,
uh, positive, uh,
feedback comes,
uh,
from uh,
what one might think of
as a model uncertainty.
There are different ways to tell the
story and I suspect it could be given much
more rigorous formalization.
Uh, then I'm going to, uh,
attempt here a prominent macro economist
early in his career developed on the
basis of some macro economic model that
he had a extremely strong view that the
British pound was going to
depreciate with great excitement.
He found an older colleague who had a
broker called the broker and explained
that he wished to place an order in the
futures market to sell the pound short.
The broker said,
okay,
I've got your order.
What would you like your stop loss to be?
Yeah.
The young macro economist said,
what's that?
The broker explained that it was normal,
that when you placed a position in
case the position moved against you,
since you didn't want to lose too much
money and if the position moved against
you,
it might signal that you didn't understand
this and things weren't playing out
according to your theory of the
case that you might want to sell.
The macro economists said,
Hell No.
If it goes up 5%,
I want to buy a lot more young
macro economists did not have had,
uh,
went on to have a very
distinguished career as a
macro economist but rather less
distinguished career as a speculator.
If I asked you,
um,
in what way would you like to place a,
you had some, you have some
conviction, you've got some idea, uh,
that the end going to go up at the end
is going to go down something.
Let's suppose it's that the yen
is going to go up and I say,
would you rather buy yen and take your
chances at the end might go up or the end
Mica Dam or would you rather
buy an option on the yen?
If you buy an option on the end,
then there's no way,
no matter what happens that you can lose
more than the amount that you paid of
for the end.
You can get very substantial leverage.
Um, on the option if you
buy an out of the money
option, you can pay only a very little
bit of money and if the end goes up,
you will multiply your, uh, initial
stake by a very substantial amount.
Most people presented with that choice
if they believe the option is priced
fairly choose to buy the option.
But if you think about what that means,
that is a decision to pursue a
positive feedback trading strategy.
That is a decision that the more
the position moves in your favor,
the more your option is in the money
and the larger is your exposure to the
underlying stock or the
underlying currency.
So anyone who chooses to use options
as a trading vehicle is choosing an
approach in which they are going to
increase the magnitude of their position.
As the price rises,
we're decrease the magnitude of
their position as the price falls.
Again,
exactly the opposite of the
natural stabilizing response.
A final source of this kind of positive,
uh,
feedback is the prospect
that increases in,
uh, movement, uh,
for any of these reasons are jumped
on by those who simply anticipate the
positive feedback behavior of others and
therefore trend follow in an effort to
front run others who are
generating these trends.
I would suggest to you that consideration
of these mechanisms along with
consideration of the
experience in markets,
a basic pattern that we
tend to observe in markets.
Positive serial correlation in the
short rod mean reversion in the long run
suggests the pervasiveness of this
kind of positive feedback behavior and
therefore suggests the likelihood that
financial markets will be subject to very
substantial instability
and multiple equilibria.
And just as the positive
feedback associated with the
bank run makes a case for
or at least opens up a case
for activist, uh, policy.
So also in the case of financial markets,
the possibility of downdrafts caused by
falling prices that lead to selling that
lead to more Sally,
uh,
lead to falling prices or updraughts
caused by the opposite mechanisms make a
potentially strong case for government
action to contain financial,
uh,
crisis.
So far I've tried to make
the case that I want to make,
uh, for, uh,
today that the macroeconomics of the
next generation will be much more about
finance and financial crisis.
Then the macroeconomics of the
generations that shaped our textbooks,
that the social gains from preventing and
containing financial crises are likely
to be significant and offer the prospect
of achieving the deep seated goal of
every Keynesian macro economist reducing
the average output gap over a long
period of time and thereby producing
more total output that a realistic theory
of financial,
uh,
crisis has to be based on something
other than the idea that the market is
efficient.
And that the notion that bank run like
behavior can be generated out of the
behavior of speculative participants in
financial markets who respond perversely
from an economist's point of view to a
price signals is a highly plausible one.
Tomorrow I hope to illustrate,
uh,
that these broad ideas have connection
with the current financial crisis,
uh,
that we face and to suggest a,
to evaluate some of the policy measures
that have been undertaken and to suggest
some policy actions for the future.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
Bob,
I don't know what the format here is,
but I'd be happy to
answer a few questions.
Yeah.
Yes,
sir.
Feedback.
I had a,
um,
I had a conclusion addressed to the word
moral hazard that I decided to defer to
the first part of what I was going to
say tomorrow. But since you ask, uh,
essentially the question I'll,
uh,
I'll address to right now.
Um,
I chose in summarizing the
main points to use the phrase,
uh,
this possibility of positive feedback,
open space for constructive government
action precisely so as to not judge with
absolutism that in every case there would
be desirable things for governments to
do, uh, precisely because of
the expectational effects, uh,
that you describe. But
it seems to me that, um,
before embracing moral hazard
and fundamentalism, uh,
and the idea that if the government gets
involved and there'll be expectations
of the government doing things
and then if their expectations,
the government doing things,
people will respond to those expectations
and then it'll surely be bad before
embracing that idea.
One needs to pause over three points.
Uh,
first moral hazard is not a
reason why there should not be,
uh,
insurance or a reason why problems,
should not be addressed
by collective action.
The standard wise crack on the subject is,
uh,
the fact that I smoked in bed is not
usually considered a good reason for the
fire department, not to come to
my house to put out the fire,
especially if my house borders very
closely on many other people's houses.
So the first point is yes,
there may be adverse act,
there may be adverse effects that come
from the expectations and there may be
beneficial effects that come from the
direct action and those have to be traded
off.
Second,
there is a certain sloppiness in supposing
that all induced behavioral changes
are to be thought of as undesirable.
Consider a standard bit of public policy.
The placing of guardrails beside highways
the government chooses as part of the
provision of a public good
to place guardrails, uh,
beside,
uh,
highways and to place good
guard rails beside highways.
It is a documented empirical fact that
is a consequence of the presence of those
guardrails.
People drive faster than
they otherwise would.
How should one think about,
as an economist,
the fact that they drive faster as in
doing a welfare evaluation of guardrails?
I think a moments thought,
uh,
should convince you that since they had
the option of driving at the same speed
that they did before in the
presence of the guardrails,
they adjusted their behavior.
The welfare gain from building
the guardrails is greater
than it would have been
if people had, is, is made,
is magnified by the behavioral
response that takes place.
So if people decide,
for example that because
we have deposit insurance,
they are not going to check
on the expressions of the
bank tellers at their bank
every day.
That I would argue is an
induced behavioral response
from a public intervention.
But it is one that magnifies the gain
from deposit insurance rather than
reducing the gain, uh, from, uh,
deposit, uh, insurance.
The third point, uh,
to be considered,
and it's getting a bit ahead of,
uh, our, uh, of our,
of our story of our story
tomorrow is that there is no,
uh,
is that one has to very carefully
consider the cost to the government of
contemplated actions.
People talk about bailouts in
a rather indiscriminate a way,
but it is a very different thing for
me to loan my friend John $1,000,
then for me to give my friend
John a thousand dollars.
And if I loan my friend,
uh,
John $1,000 at a premium interest rate
that exceeds the cost at which I borrow,
it may even be profitable for me,
uh,
to lend money to my friend John.
And if I am making a profit,
the question of in what
sense I am subsidizing him,
becomes a,
uh,
rather becomes a rather subtle, uh, one.
So take as a concrete example,
uh,
that poses, uh, the issue, uh,
the loan that the United States made to,
uh,
Mexico in uh,
1990 in 1995,
the loan that the United States
made to Mexico came at a premium of,
let's say on average about 200 basis
points over the treasury's borrowing cost.
At the time the United States made it,
Mexico would have probably been unable
to borrow at any interest rate below a
thousand basis points and perhaps
would have been unable to bop more
realistically. Probably would
have been unable to borrow at all.
So how does one think about
that 200 basis point loan?
One way to think about it is we made
a profit. 200 is more than zero.
Another way to think about
it is what weight the market,
the market price of a loan to
Mexico was a thousand basis points.
We made the loan at 200 basis points.
Therefore the loan is underwater
in the first instance.
Another way to think about it is,
well the market price is 200 basis.
The market price is a thousand points,
the thousand basis points,
but that's that it's Citibank
trying to collect from Mexico.
Probably the United States is going
to be much better at collecting, uh,
from Mexico for a variety of reasons.
Then a city group just as the Fed is
going to be much better at collecting from
Merrill Lynch, uh, then most, uh, others.
So there's considerable subtlety involved
in judging whether lending activity at
premium interest rates does or
does not constitute a subsidy.
Almost always will be profitable if paid
back relative to the lenders borrowing
cost.
Almost always it will be at
an interest rate that is low,
that is lower than the borrower
could borrow at on the markets.
And almost always in the case of
public or queasy I public activity,
there will be a reasonable
argument that the,
that the lender is better at
collecting then the private sector,
uh,
would have been.
So the question of evaluating
subsidy is a difficult,
the position that I always
took as secretary of the
treasury with respect to the
IMF was,
look,
we've got a long experience and over
time our loans have been paid back and
we've made money.
And so you can't really think
of this as bailout and subsidy.
And I think it was a
pretty strong argument.
I would want to resist
in the strongest terms,
the idea that because government
involvement will affect private sector
behavior, there is to
be some presumption, uh,
that it is to be avoided.
Yes.
The world's a very,
uh, the world's a very,
and the world is a,
a very uncertain place.
And a default risks are a very,
very,
are a very, very difficult, uh,
to, uh, to, uh, to judge.
It's a far from,
it's far from clear that
as a general matter,
investors understate to fault risks.
Indeed,
I think most people who've looked closely
at pricing patterns in bond markets
would tell you that if anything,
investors systematically
overstate default risks.
And so on a very consistent basis if
you a buy riskier bonds and sell safer
bonds that on average proofs
to VA a profitable strategy
and even proves to be a
profitable strategy adjusting for the
degree of risk that you're taking.
But the premise of a policy has,
uh,
tended to be a,
a great deal of emphasis on transparency
in the hope that with more transparency
and better information, uh, investors,
uh,
we'll make a more rational decisions
and we'll make a more rational,
uh, decisions. Uh, ex-ante.
There were also a set of
issues that are involved here.
Um, and I'll say something
about this tomorrow,
having to do with the fact
that the optimal number of
auto accidents is not zero
and the optimal number of
plane crashes is not zero.
There is a tradeoff to be
made between a accepting,
a certain possibility of accident and a
variety of advantages that come from the
conservation of capital and
the making available of, uh,
finance, uh, in a variety of ways.
Thank you very much.